good evening all it's a pleasure to be
here with you this evening it's an even
greater pleasure to introduce to you our
speaker mr. bill Gertz mr. Gertz is the
senior editor for the Washington free
beacon and national security columnist
for The Washington Times writing columns
editing and reporting on national
security for more than thirty years he
reported on China's selling of nuclear
technology to pakistan and russia's aid
to the iranian nuclear weapons program
mr. Gertz studied English Literature at
Washington College in Chestertown
Maryland and journalism at George
Washington University he's the author of
many books including the China threat
how the People's Republic targets
America and most recently I war war and
peace in the information age please join
me in welcoming mr. bill Kurtz
thank you Alex for that introduction
I want to thank Hillsdale in the Kirby
Center for having me here tonight what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna talk for 3035
minutes and and then we'll take
questions my my topic tonight is China
and national security the Gathering
Storm but a little bit of background
Alex mentioned my my book the China
threat which came out in November of
2000 right after the disputed election
between Bush and Al Gore and it was it
was a really a landmark book and the
title was basically a play on what China
calls the China threat theory and this
is a way that China looks at the world
and opposition to its modernization
program and one of the highest
priorities for its intelligence
personnel diplomats and other business
people overseas is to monitor what they
call the China threat theory and so I
chose the title to really say it's not a
theory this is this is real I was kind
of a lone voice in the wilderness at
that time and there wasn't a lot of
support for that view it was really a I
would say very minority view but one of
the reasons that I started to do that
book was that back in the late 90s as I
was reporting as a young reporter for
The Washington Times I was reporting on
the Chinese military and I went to the
Pentagon and the Defense Intelligence
Agency provided a background briefing
and it was was pretty vanilla it was not
real solid but it was it was an
interesting talk but toward the end of
it a colonel came in and said the
general would like to see you and the
general was the director of the Defense
Intelligence Agency and we sat down in a
conference room and either end and he
declared to me at this meeting he said
bill China is not a threat and I was a
little surprised and I said my first
question as a reporter is well why do
you think that and his answer to
summarize was basically because the
Chinese say they're not a threat and I
knew that this was a real problem
I said I
understand he made perhaps he was trying
to spin me but really what it was was a
reflection of the views of his analyst
in his agency at that time and it would
turn out that one of those key analysts
was a Defense Intelligence Agency
analyst named Ron Monta Pardo who turned
out to be a Chinese spy he wasn't
convicted of spying but he was convicted
of mishandling classified information
and as part of the plea agreement he
admitted to passing classified
information to two Chinese defense
attache at the embassy here in
Washington so what I'm going to go
through very quickly tonight is kind of
a preview of what I call the China
Threat 2.0 and that was what the title
of my next book is going I wanted it to
be but the publisher had different idea
and I've just finished a book on China
which is really the China Threat 2.0
which looks at the issues related to
China and how we got it wrong which is
really a story in itself and that book
will be out it's called deceiving the
sky inside communist China's drive for
global supremacy and deceiving the sky
is a ancient Chinese strategy which says
deceive the sky to cross the ocean you
know it's one of those mandate of heaven
type things but it basically means that
you for the Chinese and military
strategy you must be willing to deceive
the Emperor or to deceive heaven in
order to achieve your goals and this is
very much what we're seeing today with
Communist China a little history of US
policy towards China in the past
up until the Trump administration we've
seen 40 years of basically engagement
and conciliation and business ties and
this was a what I call a 30-year gamble
and the gamble was based on the idea
that and this was formal policy in
presidential directives and other
policies within all of the various parts
of the government which was if we trade
with China and we engage China and we
treat China as an
nation it will become a normal nation
guess what it was utter failure and and
the reason for that failure hasn't been
fully explained yet in fact the people
who are responsible for that failure
haven't quite admitted that they're
wrong but they're they're getting close
to it
so what happened with president Trump's
election Trump was very different from
previous administrations both Republican
and Democrat in their approach to China
Trump as as early as the early 2000s
broke with the business community on
China and said he understood that China
does pose a threat from his point of
view it was mainly an economic threat in
his 2012 book the America we deserve
which again was in preparation for him
to run for president back then which he
decided not to but in the book he said
he broke with the business community on
human rights grounds on America first
grounds and and that's really came to
the fore after his election in 2017
China was one of his three highest
priorities dealing with immigration was
another but but the China problem and
one of the very first meetings that
Trump had in Trump Tower he met with the
captains of industry in Silicon Valley
and every one of them all they had to
say was we're getting killed by China
they're stealing our intellectual
property they're stealing our technology
and it's going to put us out of business
and it's going to destroy the country it
was it was an alarm and so he then said
about doing policies that were going to
change this and so the one of the very
key things that he did was he made a
much more clear linkage between American
national security interests and economic
security so he's really joined together
national security and economic security
and that's kind of where his specialty
comes from so he's oriented his policies
that way from someone like me who's been
covering the military and security and
defense issues he's not done enough on
the on the defense and national security
side but I'm patient I think I think he
will get to that
so he's been focused primarily on
pressuring China economically and he's
really said he said many times that our
past agreements our past deals with
China have all heard us have all hurt
the country hurt its economy and
ultimately heard it's it's national
security militarily there's been some
pressure and some and also some
continuity for example the military
exchange program which I've been a vocal
critic of for many years is one of these
programs that has been on autopilot for
the past thirty years and the idea
behind the military exchange program is
that well if we go and we meet with the
Chinese military and we visit their
ships and they visit our ships and we
have high-level visits that this is
going to quote build trust it's a
fundamental fallacy first of all it's a
fundamental fallacy because it's it
fails to understand the nature of the
People's Liberation Army this is not a
national army this is a party army
that's devoted to one thing not
defending China it's devoted to keeping
the Communist Party of China in power
and this so treating them as just a
normal military has been a real mistake
and this idea that they're going to
build trust was was exposed back in 2001
they they had years of exchanges where
they would have phone calls and then we
had an incident where a Chinese pilot
ran into one of our surveillance
aircraft killed himself in the crash and
almost killed our air crews and that
landed on Hainan Island and so our guys
called up and said you know General John
can you pick up the phone well there was
no answer and the reason there was no
answer is because again this is a party
army though Chinese general could ever
risk being quote friends or even
trusting the Americans and I'll get into
that in in the ideology section but on
the intelligence front there's also some
relatively good news there there has
been a crackdown on Chinese economic gas
Minhaj the Justice Department recently
announced a program to go after the
Chinese and they've been doing it in a
very successful way the Chinese are
still conducting both human intelligence
operations as well as cyberattacks to
get into all of our systems and it it's
not too late but in in a large measure
the damage has been extensive and I'll
also touch on that a little bit too so
what has changed in December of 2017
2017 the White House issued its new
national security strategy and for the
first time China was described as a
challenge this is short of being an
enemy but it is a challenge it's a
strategic challenge and the reason
that's a compromised term because the
describing China as a enemy would put it
in a different category and forced all
the current engagement that we have the
massive economic engagement but it was a
step forward and it says that they're
against American power influence
interests they're attempting to erode
American security and prosperity they're
making economies less free and less fair
they're growing their military way
beyond the original idea that this was
just a from a Constabulary army to a
power projection army for taking back
Taiwan now they have global aspirations
and global ambitions which have made
them a much greater threat they're also
controlling information and data to
repress their own society and expand
their influence following the national
security strategy there was the net of
the defense security strategy which was
issued by the Pentagon a month later and
it basically also identified China as a
strategic competitor which is using
predatory economics to intimidate its
neighbors while militarizing features in
the South China Sea according to the the
new defense strategy China wants to
shape the world consistent with its
authoritarian model they didn't go so
far as to say that this is
still a nuclear-armed communist
dictatorship but they they are
recognizing that this is a bigger
challenge than just a nation that we've
been trading with so China is leveraging
its military modernization influence
operations and predatory economics to
coerce neighboring countries as part of
a plan to reorder the indo-pacific
region to their advantage and in so
doing they're using an all of nation
approach which combines military
diplomatic intelligence economic
financial it's across the board and
they're going for regional hegemony the
the strategy didn't say that they have
global ambitions but it's clear that
they do and and that will be the next
step once they recognize that the next
point I wanted to touch on was back in
October vice president pence gave a
speech on China which again was a very
landmark statement for US policy towards
China and it was very very well done in
the sense of outlining the the nature of
the threat that China poses he he said
China's again using economic diplomatic
military means to expand its influence
in proactive ways and that the Trump
administration's new approach is based
on fairness reciprocity and respect for
sovereignty pence pointed out that since
1991 the United States has made major
trade concessions major economic
concessions to China and the idea was
that this was going to lead to a free
and prosperous and open China but pence
recognized that he said this was a hope
that has been unfulfilled the other
thing that China has been doing is they
also announced their plans it's most of
their military developments are done in
secret ways but they're their main
strategies have been announced in public
and they've done that through a number
of means one of which is called the made
in China 2025 initiative this is a
an economic blueprint that says that
China is going to first of all identify
and then corner all of the major
high-technology markets so that China
has complete control over them just
imagine 5g robotics artificial
intelligence unmanned aerial vehicles
all of these key technologies are
they're going to corner the market after
pence identified this as part of their
strategy interestingly enough the
Chinese issued a directive to their
propaganda ministry which leaked out
that said no more mention of made in
China 2025 and I think that tells you
how important that is the other thing is
that they the idea that China was going
to become more open and free has has
been also a fallacy
instead we're seeing greater repression
and we're seeing repression that's being
assisted by advanced technologies
another key feature that pence talked
about which again didn't get much
attention at the time was that he said
that China was using its formidable
powers of influence to meddle in the US
elections and he was very blunt Trump
first announced this in September at the
United Nations and then pence later on
said I gave this speech outlining what
he said was China wants a different
American president and he quoted from a
leaked propaganda and censorship notice
that said quote strike accurately and
carefully splitting apart different
domestic groups in the US and then pence
also quoted a senior US intelligence
official is saying that Russian
influence operations pale in comparison
to what China is doing and of course
we're all aware of the the main
narrative that has been in our
mainstream media about the Russian
conspiracy theory which is beginning to
be debunked as recently as last weekend
with the the bottom line on the Moller
report there's still problems like
say the US government policies are like
a gigantic super tanker and it takes a
lot to get them to turn so even now when
both mattes was defense secretary and
Pompeyo as as Secretary of State in
October last year they had a meeting
with Chinese officials and after the
meeting they they they came out both of
them in different formats said the
United States is quote not out to
contain China this is again one of the
boilerplate pro-china
conciliatory narratives that has been
used for decades which needs to be
debunked my answer to that is why not
contain China why shouldn't we contain
China and that's the debate that the
country needs to have a few points about
Chinese ideology I think this is
extremely important for again for many
many years
the idea that China is ruled by the
Communist Party of China and by
communist ideology has been played down
I can remember doing a panel discussion
in New York it was a debate on China and
one of the panelists was a businessman
who said he told me afterwards he said
I've been doing business in China for
twenty years and I've never met a
communist and I was shocked because I've
been to China a number of times mostly
on with official travel covering defense
secretaries and all you need to do is go
to the military Museum in in Beijing
they have statues of Marx Lenin angles
all the communist leaders they try to
play down the fact that they say the
Chinese aren't really a communist regime
anymore this is this is totally false
the Chinese ideology it is derived from
Soviet Marxism Leninism
and what has happened is that there's
been a division among the elites in the
US over China and one is what I call the
historical school they look at China
from the historical perspective and they
say that oh they're not really communist
this is the way the Chinese have been
throughout their history it's really
just the latest iteration of Chinese
history and then on the other side
there are those who say no that's not
true that this is a communist regime and
that it's motivated by communism and
those two views have been at odds with
each other and are still we still have
not resolved this debate we still need a
debate the current Chinese leader Xi
Jinping he has advocated a new iteration
of Marxism Leninism with Chinese
characteristics which has been dubbed
the Chinese dream and the Chinese dream
is basically a ripoff of the American
dream applied to Chinese communism and
the Chinese dream is really something
that will look at how China can become
the global power and they use the
concept of Chinese historical resentment
and that China has to maintain its place
as the world power so they are driving
for global supremacy again we don't hear
much about that we we don't we don't
have discussions about that we're
starting to see more of that but in
reality the PRC is a revolutionary
communist state and it engages in what
is called enemy politics a key feature
of Chinese ideology is opposition to the
United States they see the United States
is some grand conspiracy to quote
contain China and prevent China from
becoming a global hegemon that it that
it deserves to be
again Xi Jinping is a central figure he
came to power in 2012 and since that
time he has accumulated more personal
power than even Mao had at the height of
his personality cult and that resulted
in the most recent 19th Party Congress
where he did away with the term limits
making himself essentially president for
life and he also enshrined his Xi
Jinping thought again his Chinese dream
and his concepts within the Chinese
Constitution also all is not well in
China we we don't have good intelligence
you know and I'll get to that and and
briefly
through it but there was an incident
that took place in February of 2012 that
was really showed that China is not this
monolithic stable massive state and what
what happened was that a senior official
of a regional party police intelligence
chief his name was Wang Lijun defected
to the US consulate in Chengdu China and
this set in motion was almost a major
power struggle because this person who
was defecting brought with him a large
number of Secrets he made it he came in
disguised and because he had fled the
leader in in Chengdu was a guy named Bo
Sheila who is a regional almost a neo
MAOIs leader he used to have big rallies
and people would wave Communist flags
he sent military forces after this
defector to surround the consulate they
have photos were posted on the internet
did anyone see those photos in any of
our newspapers from no because it didn't
get any coverage there were actually
photos of people's armed police armored
vehicles heading to Chengdu to get this
guy back so there was a massive standoff
between these two Regent this regional
leader boshi boshi lai and the leaders
in Beijing Xi Jinping and it was
resolved after the u.s. decided not to
accept this defector and this was a
State Department decision which was a
huge mistake and they actually turned
him over to the Beijing authorities
Hillary Clinton wrote in her book that
the reason that she did that was that
she did she wanted didn't want to
embarrass the Beijing leaders and this
thing happened right before the the vice
president at the time Xi Jinping was
about to come to Washington to meet
Biden so it was it was a real scandal
not only did we lose our key
intelligence source who could have
provided details about inside of the
regime but the it was also covered up in
order to
protect the leadership in Beijing how
did we get China so wrong for so long
well that's that's a subject that's
beginning to be discussed there was an
article in foreign affairs by Kurt
Campbell and Eli Ratner who were two
officials of the Obama administration
and they triggered a debate and the
debate in the headline was did America
get China wrong and the answer for me
was clear they did of course the the pro
China analysts and pro China academics
disputed that they're still on this idea
that if we just trade with China it will
become a normal non communist state it's
it's not happened so we've also seen
what I call hi-tech totalitarianism
emerge in China the use of surveillance
means artificial intelligence large
databases in order to control the
population
they now have something in China called
the Social Credit system and this is a
credit system that is based on politics
it's not based on whether you pay your
bills or not it's based on whether or
not you're considered good enough to be
able to be part of the communist system
and if you're not you can't travel on
aircraft you can't travel on trains you
can't get work and it's it's a new means
of control that is leveraged with high
technology another key area that China
has been working on and I guess I'll go
through this quickly because I'm already
going to be over my time here is too
much but on the military side of things
China has done two things that are
they've done a number of things probably
five or six areas but the two main
asymmetric warfare areas that they've
done is in space warfare and in cyber
warfare and these are two areas where
the Chinese are either on par with the
United States or in some areas they're
ahead of the United States and that's
something that has a lot of people
concerned in terms of their space
capabilities
they have achieved back in 2007 you
probably remember that they did what was
called an anti-satellite missiles test
and this was firing a ground-based
missile and having enough accuracy and
maneuverability to shoot down a
satellite that was orbiting 300 miles in
space what they didn't realize was that
this satellite debris created a massive
debris field that is now surrounding the
earth and will continue to threaten both
manned and unmanned spacecraft for
probably a hundred years so they changed
course after that no more blowing up
satellites now they're using missile
defense to cover up to as a cover for
their anti satellite program but they're
they're doing not just missiles but
they're also doing small Co orbital
satellites that is maneuvering
satellites that are capable of guiding
themselves right next to a satellite and
then they have a robotic arm that can
grab and crush those satellites they've
developed a ground-based laser system
that and this is the what the experts
say is the most effective way to disable
an orbiting satellite without creating
debris all you need to do is have a
high-powered laser fired at an orbiting
satellite and if you hit the optics or
the sensors on that it can melt the
glass on it and it can also fry the
electronics inside of it and it and
there's no way that is very difficult to
detect that so they're space warfare
capability is its formidable in terms of
cyber we we've all heard but only
recently how formidable their cyber
warfare capabilities are and I would
point to the hack of the Office of
Personnel Management where they stole
over 22 million records of all federal
workers including some of the most
sensitive data on security clearance
forms when when anyone applies for a
security clearance they have to go in
and they tell about their neighbors they
tell about every personality defect they
have every the most smallest personal
details China has that now and this is a
and they're they're using that applying
artificial and tell
software to be able to find people who
have access to the computer networks
they want and they can target them to
get access to them or they can use it
for human spine it's a major major
compromise I want to mention Huawei
Technologies briefly in December the
u.s. arrested the number three official
in Huawei Technologies a woman named
Ming lanzhou she's the daughter of the
founder of Huawei Huawei masquerades
itself as a private company but in
reality it is lock stock and barrel part
of the Chinese Communist Party system of
private and semi-private companies and
this is a company that is leading the
charge to gain total control over 5g
technology the emerging technology of 5g
networks this is a court case we don't
have all the details but basically they
use the law and the law was that we have
imposed sanctions on Iran that prevents
Iran from using the financial system
well Huawei and Hmong were able to
misuse that system and do business with
Iran and that's that case is coming out
all right I'm gonna go to my solutions
and then I'm gonna wrap that'll wrap it
up and then I'll take your questions and
we can go right to questions we've had a
number of Chinese spy cases already
there have been three of us officials in
the CIA and dia who have been caught
spying for China and and I mentioned
earlier that it's been an utter disaster
starting in 2010 as many as 30 as many
as 30 as many as 30 recruited agents
were compromised so the CIA basically
lost all of its agent network in in
China and they don't even they're not
even sure how it happened one of the
people they've arrested a former CIA
officer Jerry Chun Singh Lee was found
with a notebook with the names and cover
names for a number of these agents so
you know as I say in the FBI that's a
clue he probably gave it to the Chinese
there's also the idea that an
internet-based system of communicating
with agents was compromised and it was
compromised in Iran and the same system
was used in China and Chinese
intelligence was able to get inside of
that communication system so we lost all
of our agents there it's mantilla bigger
intelligence disaster at a time when we
need better intelligence on China of
course we heard nothing about this
during the Obama administration when it
happened it was basically covered up but
it was an intelligence disaster all
right so what do we do how do we how do
we solve the problem and I'll I'll make
some some pop some policy
recommendations that'll be in my
forthcoming book the first thing we have
to do is to is to recognize that the
People's Republic of China and the
ruling Communist Party of China are an
enemy they're not just a strategic
competitor we have to start declaring
them as an enemy and once we do that we
have to begin disengagement with China
now we can't completely disengage we're
we're vested in a lot of ways
economically with China but we need to
begin disengaging we need to be doing
that that's that's we have to do that
the second thing we need to do to
counter China is to follow the Reagan
administration model of using financial
warfare Ronald Reagan beginning in 1982
launched a brilliant campaign of
financial warfare against the Soviet
Union and basically it was done at the
White House they figured out that the
Soviet Union was overextended
financially and they were able to put
the screws on the Soviet Union and
basically financially basically drive a
dagger in the heart of Moscow and it
took until night and a-91 for it to
collapse but it was essentially a
financial means the same thing can be
done with China it's a little bit
different we're seeing right now the
balance of the trade war going on and
and tariffs and counter tariffs but but
the real threat is to our capital
markets
China is heavily invested in the capital
markets and they're using that money to
build up their military there are no
repeat no US national security controls
on China allowing to be invested in our
capital markets that's hedge funds
pension funds and over-the-counter
trading this is going to be an issue
that's going to come up you're going to
be hearing more about that the other
thing we need to do this goes back to my
book I wore it's more aggressive
information operations America has
tremendous military and economic power
and diplomatic and intelligence power
but we're very weak and when it comes to
information power we currently have a
20th century information system we're
spending 700 million a year on Voice of
America and a number of radios that are
structured for the last century they're
not in the digital age they're not in
prepared to deal with the kinds of
information threats we're seeing from
both China and Russia so we need to
reform that the other thing is strict
reciprocity we've got to start imposing
strict reciprocity on Chinese
investments Chinese activities for
example the Confucius Institutes these
are funded institutes by the Chinese
government that are part of their
influence operations there's more than a
hundred in the United States and they're
having a tremendous negative impact on
our universities because they provide
money to these universities they they're
allowing the the policies not to discuss
Chinese human rights abuses not to
discuss Chinese aggressive activities in
the South China Sea and that type of
thing so we've got to stop that and the
way the do it is to say okay for every
Confucius Institute that's at a unit s
university we need to have a comparable
u.s. funded Hamilton Jefferson Institute
at a Chinese University which will have
the same type of activities teach
English and teach about American values
and democracy increased intelligence and
counterintelligence I talked about the
intelligence failures we need a new
Democratic Alliance in Asia we never
were able to do this in the past because
there were many non communist
authoritarian states there but now
there's a much larger Democratic
community we need to organize them and
focus on on demanding that China reform
its communist system and bring about
some type of democratic reform the last
thing I point out is we need to play the
Russia card this is an important
strategic idea right now we're unable to
do that because of Vladimir Putin I
think it's very possible that the US
could use non-military means to help
bring about Democratic Pro US government
in Russia and that's really urgent what
we need I would just sum up by saying
that the China threat that we're facing
today is far greater than anything we're
facing from Russia and it's going to
take all of America's resources its will
it's its efforts to to deal with that
threat in the coming years and I'll stop
there thank you very much
[Applause]
question yeah thank you for coming my
name is mitsuna kaya Japan native you're
a citizen my question is can you talk
about the balance of power in the
asia-pacific region it's very important
I'm talking about China I'm talking
about Japan and the whole shebang I have
my own idea but I want to hear what you
think thank you okay
yeah the balance of power again the US
military and intelligence system has Mis
estimated China they believed that for
many years China was only building up
forces for one thing and that was to
retake Taiwan across the hundred-mile
straight and take over that island it
was false there hasn't been an
assessment on why it was false and there
needs to be one but what has happened
instead is that China has expanded its
military capabilities again using with
us with a major emphasis on naval power
they've been cranking out ships they've
stolen the aegis battle management
system and they've not only stolen it
but they're now actually putting out
ships that have this they've stolen
every major technology we have they
they'd recently fired a railgun
which is a high-speed kinetic projectile
they built it before we actually they
deployed it before we've actually done
it so the balance is shifting I think in
terms of undersea warfare the unit the
u.s. still has an advantage with its
both attack submarines and its nuclear
submarines but that advantage is is is
fairly quickly eroded so there needs to
be a much greater emphasis on
challenging China in these key military
areas I'm Peter
Intel analyst and a former diplomat the
thing that's striking to me is that
somewhere in the 50s we made the
observation that Soviet Union would
never improve the world that we would
always see a worsening situation and it
was better to start in the 50s to begin
the long term campaign to degrade the
comest party in Russia I don't see that
decision being made by any
administration now there's no secret
committee in the NSC to begin the
process and I see two striking
opportunities that we seem to be missing
one is to break the Great Firewall
there's no reason we shouldn't start
right now with drones and hundreds of
radio stations to break that information
hold so that the Chinese people can see
the level of corruption let's declassify
some of the corruption and feed it back
into China we don't have to declare a
war all you have to do is break the
information all the other one is Chinese
handing us a gift locking up Cossacks
and Leaguers why aren't we energized to
go to the Muslim world to lead the
charge for wants to defend Muslims and
say please come onboard no belts no Road
until every Muslim is free in China very
good very good points on the second
point basically yeah we need we have to
do that this is what gets back to my
thing about information operations we
don't have the government doesn't have a
good information system to be able to
make that case they just don't have it I
mean our our VOA and our radios are
built on a journalistic model that was
good for the 20th century but it's
something that we it's not useful now as
to the Soviet Union part of it in
getting that wrong there's there's I'm I
just read a recent book called Russia's
dead end which was about a gorbachev
insider who talked about how they were
trying to take down the
the Soviet Union they basically were
dismantling it it was a small group of
reformers within the foreign ministry
and they were they were very successful
until Yeltsin came in after the 91 coup
and at that point the security services
reacted and the other problem he said
was that Russia didn't have any
democratic foundation and the West
didn't help them to develop a democratic
foundation to build on this this tiny
Democratic tree that they had planted so
the result was Putin came back into
power I think the same can be applied
for China one of my recommendations is
that the US should create a parliament
in exile get Pro Democrats together have
them meet once a year
have them debate on how they would
change things in China put those
together publish them and then get him
back in I agree with you on the
information I would mention one thing
there there is some really positive
things going on in terms of opposition
one of them is a fellow named grow Wang
week who's an exiled Chinese billionaire
living in New York and he is working to
bring about the reform he wants to end
the rule of the Communist Party and he
wants to bring rule of law to China and
he's created a huge following inside
China his slogan is everything is just
beginning and people in China who wear
t-shirts that say everything is just
beginning our being in prison so they're
cracking down on it they they they want
to kill him they want to try to silence
him they've tried to get him forcibly
repatriated they've used American
businessmen to lobby on that case I'll
have the story in my forthcoming book
but one of the programs he wants to fund
with his billions is launching
satellites over China now now it's
capable it's possible to launch small
communication satellites and potentially
what you could do is get these
satellites over China and then have
people smuggle in breaking the Great
Firewall of getting an app on their
handheld because most people in China
don't use iPads or laptops they use
handhelds and get them to be able to
have
open Internet access directly so those
are the kinds of things that could be
done it takes will and political will
but first thing we have to solve this
debate we have to get over the the
debate between the two sides the ones
who say that China will eventually
evolve between the others who say no
we've we've got to push them in that
direction yep let's do Reuter retired
submarine officer let me give you two
code words to talk about one is facial
recognition and the other is EMP
electromagnetic pulse okay
the facial recognition gets to the
high-tech totalitarianism and they're
definitely doing that there they're not
only doing facial recognition but again
they're applying artificial intelligence
to it which means they're actually
getting machines to be able to sift out
these masses of pictures they also have
technology that can measure people
skills identity through their gait and
EMP there's a debate on EMP in fact just
as I was coming over here there was
there was a report that Trump is going
to issue some executive order addressing
the EMP threat EMP is the the blast that
comes from a nuclear device not not the
blast but the electronic wave a pulse
that comes from a nuclear device and
this pulse can destroy all electronics
over an area about a thousand miles we
first learned about it in 1964 when we
did a test in the Pacific we set off an
atmospheric test on one of these small
islands and it made the streetlights in
Honolulu go out and so they realized
that this was a weapon and both the
Chinese and the Russians are working on
EMP weapons because it it you don't have
to use the blast you can fire one of
these things in space a hundred miles up
to
miles in space and it will have the same
effect so it is a concern others have
tried to downplay the the threat from
EMP and their argument is if anybody's
going to fire a nuclear blast they're
going to they're going to invite
immediate nuclear retaliation so that's
the question that that people have on on
EMP yes over there hi my name is Ramona
Winkle Bauer you did a wonderfully
thorough job on the military and a
pretty good job on the business side you
briefly touched on the Confucian
Institute's but you left out the for the
most part the universities and basically
the wholesale gift of scientific
knowledge to not only China but the rest
of the world how would you change that
if we could that issue is definitely on
the radar for the Trump administration
they're definitely trying to figure out
how to do that there's been pushback
from the academic and research community
they're saying oh you're you're going to
undermine the ability of the u.s. to
conduct high technology research but
they're there there needs to be and
Trump has been very clear on this
you know the estimates in a White House
did a report on this they the the title
said something about China's economic
aggression against the United States and
there was a battle over that we can't
say aggression and they decided they
needed to say that but they the
estimates are that between two hundred
billion and five hundred billion
annually of stolen technology and
otherwise illicit Lee acquired
technology so this is a this is a real
problem and part of that is that there's
so many of these researchers Chinese
have come to this country we've have
300,000 students and researchers here
there has been no effort to do
counterintelligence on them not all of
them are spies some of them are
legitimate students but again it goes
back to this whole thing if they're a
competitor and they're competing against
us and they wanted
eat us then we've got to take steps to
prevent them from stealing our
technology yeah but you hi my name is
Aaron Wong I'm just an intern but I
would like to ask about Taiwan and the
place you see it playing in the future
of us-china tensions yeah Taiwan is is
really a democratic dagger pointed at
the heart of China it really is
it's as you know the Taiwanese were
created in 1949 during the Civil War in
on the mainland the Nationalists fled to
the island
it was never resolved when the u.s.
recognized Beijing and D recognized
Taiwan and it's it's been left ambiguous
and that ambiguity is in the current
environment is is kind of dangerous
there needs to be greater clarity we
need to finally recognize that this is
an independent state China regards
Taiwan as a breakaway province the good
news is the Trump administration is
doing things that haven't been done in a
long time the President signed the
Taiwan Travel Act which which was new
legislation that said it's okay for
senior US government and military
officials to travel to the island and
this is extremely important because when
when taiwan was d recognized and beijing
was recognized Congress stepped in to
protect what was an old ally in Taiwan
and they passed 1979 Taiwan Relations
Act the Taiwan Relations Act says that
the US will provide defensive armaments
to the island and will prevent the
mainland from conducting a assault to
try and take over Taiwan so that's been
the heart of our policy and it's in law
it's not it can't be changed by
executive order and so this was really
important a important step but over the
years again there's been this major
shift towards the mainland
we haven't sold them weapons the Chinese
now have 1200 ballistic missiles
targeted at Taiwan the Taiwan military
is in need of modernization and I just
reported last week that the
administration has approved the sale of
new f16 jets to the island which are
needed I remember meeting a Taiwanese
general back in 2009 and he said look
our pilots don't mind dying in combat
but they don't want to die in training
accidents because their planes are
falling out of the sky for lack of parts
or maintenance so Taiwan is a very
important thing it needs to be clarified
the the records of the meetings with
Henry Kissinger during the Nixon period
were they said let's leave it unsettled
so it's been an unsettled issue and it's
it still remains a flashpoint in in
us-china relations yeah you had a
question making a ton of money
generating factories and transferring US
intellectual property in China
at the same time we're sitting here
trying to defend them and so they're
taking advantage of their relationship
with China while at the same time they
take advantage of their relationship
with the United States about defense so
my name is Warren ticker of I come first
part of my life under socialism I'm from
Bulgaria originally so we operate now
with all these labels Chinese Communists
their dictatorship were Democrats were
capitalists if you look under the labels
in China today people are much more
responsible for their lives than in this
country they pay for their education for
their healthcare they don't have the
welfare system that we have bloomed here
and all these things here describing is
because 30 years ago they had lower
percentage of population colleges that
US had in 19th century today they are
producing ten times more than students
that we're producing and
they have national political elites who
are completely committed to the national
interest what do we have in our country
we call cell democracy markets who have
been shifting more and more towards
income redistribution we're creating
massive population dependent on the
government we're losing our
competitiveness our universities have
become politically correct boring places
where free discussion is not welcome and
our elites who are supposed to be the
best because they're produced through
our democratic process have been
short-sighted corrupted dumb you know
you pick your words so my question for
you is maybe it's time for us to
actually start learning from China and
see how they produce these results that
are threatening to us right in just
being stuck in these stereotypes
communist Democrats we good they bad
yeah because we're in competition with
them whether we like them or not okay
and we have to be better
I disagree there's they're they're
spreading a model that if if China's
model for what they want to do which is
a totalitarian based communist model if
it becomes the world standard it's not
going to be a world you want to live in
and it's not going to be a world any of
our children want to live in either
that's that's my comment on that yeah
this is the final question okay hello
I'm John a congressional staffer could
you talk a little bit about the
implications of the New Deal that China
is making with Italy and even some of
the comments of McCrone and Merkel about
increased relations with China yeah I
comment rather than just Italy I'd say
it's it's part of this what's known as
the belt and road initiative
I've got a story that's coming tomorrow
in the free beacon that talks about
China developing a new missile a new
long-range land attack cruise missile
that's fired from a shipping container
this is something the Russians have done
they have a club K missile this this new
missile is represents a really new
threat because it comes out at a time
when they're doing this belt and Road
initiative the belt and Road initiative
is China's effort to
expand its infrastructure influence
access to ports access to facilities
around the world and they're investing
at least a trillion dollars in it and
their target is again to get control of
the financial system ultimately they
want a yuan based economy in the world
and not a dollar based economy and a lot
of countries are signing up to it a lot
of countries are using are being victims
of what is known as debt diplomacy where
the Chinese will offer loans and then
when the countries can't pay back the
loans they'll demand a port and
facilities like that we haven't had a
lot of media coverage of the Belden Road
initiative this is this is part of that
this is part of that and it's something
that needs to be covered it needs to be
discussed it needs to be debated okay
all right thank you very much
[Applause]